it's thin and it's fanless how is that
possible
hey guys it's vadim with max tech and
i'm extremely excited because right here
in front of me
we have three 2021 ipad pros
this is the 11 inch and these are two
12.9 inchers
one has eight gigs of ram one has 16
but we're going to leave this for
another video because this video
is based on thermal throttling we got
the 11 inch because
it's a smaller chassis and we're gonna
see if the m1
chip the crazy m1 chip thermal throttles
in this ipad pro because it's super thin
and we're going to do that by comparing
it to the m1 macbook pro which has a fan
it it does not throttle at all so in
this video we're going to be doing a
bunch of testing
i have my seek thermal camera that i
have right here we're going to be doing
the thermals
checking them between these two then i
have my
thunderbolt ssd we're going to be
testing out the new thunderbolt port on
this guy to see if it's slower
or if it's just as fast as on the m1
macbook pro and we're going to be doing
a ton
of benchmarks to see if this 11 inch
ipad pro with the m1
does in fact throttle or not so without
further ado
let's begin all right there we go that
was a fast unboxing huh
everybody's out there doing unboxing
videos but we're like screw the unboxing
let's get into the real stuff that you
guys care about thermal throttling and
performance
so i do want to mention a couple of
things first thing i notice that
is that these uh speaker grills right
here they are
kind of closer to the center we used to
have more of them more on the outside
and that is important because if you're
holding it like this let's say playing a
game
before you would be blocking the bottom
speaker grills and now
you're not as much so that's pretty nice
but other than that
basically everything else is identical
so we're not gonna
really be looking at that we're just
gonna start this ipad up
we're going to set it up and then we're
going to start the testing i have
geekbench 5 open right here as you can
see it says arm
at 3.2 gigahertz that's the new m1 chip
we got 8 gigs of ram
but before we do this test i want to
grab the magic keyboard case
plop this on there and i do want to show
you guys one little difference
with the camera as you can see this is
the original view still a little bit
weird because the webcam is right here
but we do have a new widescreen button
there you go
ultra wide look at that that is actually
nice because it works with their new
center stage feature so it kind of crops
in moves with you that is cool we're
actually going to be comparing this
to the 2020 ipad pro in our next video
so if you're not already subscribed
do so right now but now let's get into
those benchmarks
all right we got our scores and this is
a huge surprise because based on the
benchmarks that were leaked earlier
we did not see this the m1 ipad pro only
scored
63.50 compared to 76.52
so that means that the m1 macbook pro
that does not throttle
is 20 faster in terms of the multi-core
performance
we did not expect that so we are seeing
some thermal throttling already which is
kind of weird but if we compare the m1
to the a12z 2020 ipad pro
it is 35 faster in terms of the
multi-core so that's still a really good
improvement
and it's 53 faster in terms of the
single core
1718 compared to 1123 so that's a huge
improvement
but in terms of the single core between
both of these it's within a margin of
error
so we're really only seeing that 20
difference in the multi-core now let's
move on
to the metal test and while this is
running i do want to mention that we
just got the 24-inch imac
it's waiting for another video we're
gonna be doing that next so if you're
not already subscribed
do so right now so you don't miss that
oh my goodness guys i was not expecting
that because based off the
multi-core score it was throttling but
this is insane
this is within a margin of error look at
that it's only what around like 120
points off
i cannot believe that the m1 chip is
scoring
this well in that fin of a chassis
that is just insane 21
600 points and just to quickly show you
guys this is the old a12z
the new m1 is 82 faster in terms of
graphics performance
that is just crazy that's so good this
is what i call
future proof now before i move on to the
other thermal throttle testing
i do want to test out the new
thunderbolt port using this
sabrint extreme ssd this has crazy fast
speeds
so we're going to be transferring stuff
to both of these to see if
the ipad pro does it a little bit slower
maybe i got my stopwatch ready right
here i'm going to be
transferring a file this folder has
about 58
gigabytes so i'm gonna see how long it
takes
and go all right looks like it says
about a minute and it's going very fast
as you can see
this is probably one of the best ssds
you can buy
right now we're gonna have a link down
in the description below just in case
you want one of these because it works
for the ipad pro too
all right we're almost done and there
you go
one minute and 13 seconds to transfer
that folder gonna unplug it
and move that over and plug it into the
m1 ipad pro let's go ahead into the
files app and there you go four terabyte
ssd we can see it right there prep my
timer and we should be able to just drag
and drop
just like that go it doesn't really give
us a progress bar but
i'm gonna have to look at it oh this
operation can't be completed it was not
able to transfer that file all right
well i'm gonna try it again then
that is weird looks like it's not able
to
transfer it the reason it's probably not
working is because we have files in here
that
are not compatible like a final cut
library
maybe that's why but uh let's try
something else like this
16 gig video file there you go it
transferred and
54 seconds 54 seconds for 16 gigs
so i'm going to unplug this and try it
again on the m1 macbook pro with that
file to see if it's faster but before i
do that i do want to transfer some video
files and some photos because we are
going to be doing a thermal
throttling test using lightroom and
adobe rush
we're back on the m1 pro we have the
same 16 gig
file let's see how long this takes much
faster what in the world okay there you
go it's done
under 20 seconds 19.68
so as we can see the ipad pro took 54
seconds
compared to 20 so it's taking twice as
long almost three times longer
so it does seem like it is a little bit
throttled i don't know why
but it's definitely not as fast as on a
mac
all right now let's move on to our next
test this is the gfx bench
metal cross platform benchmark as we
already know in the geekbench 5 metal
there really wasn't that big of a
difference it was within a margin of
error
so this is going to be kind of a longer
more real world test we're doing the
1440p
aztec ruins and let's go ahead and
start it guys this is insane all right
so we just got to scores 82.6 fps on the
ipad pro
81.4 on the m1 macbook pro
it actually beat it in this real world
gaming benchmark
that is crazy now let's move on to the
next test we have 3dmark wild
life extreme i don't know why this one's
flipped but
let's go ahead and hit start for some
reason this one's loading faster than
the m1 macbook pro i don't know why
all right we're done and this is really
weird i'm not sure what's going on
but the m1 macbook pro only got 4 900
points
about 30 fps compared to 17
000 i don't know what happened but all i
know is
this is killing it i don't think it's
throttling at all
that's just crazy and now just because
i'm curious i do want to run the
speedometer
browser benchmark just to see how web
browsing and stuff like that
is going to be running and if there is
any kind of a difference or any kind of
throttling
on the ipad all right there we have it
basically the same score
230 and 231 by the way that's
the most insane browsing performance you
can get right now like this beat out
every other mac every other computer
that we had the m1 chip is just crazy
for web browsing because of that single
core performance
and now this is going to be the serious
test
we have lightroom opened up on both of
these and we have
50 raw photos these are 42 megapixel
photos that we usually use for our mac
tests
open right here so the first thing we're
going to do is test out i guess
responsiveness so
let's switch and it does seem like
the mac is going faster than the ipad
pro looks like there's a little bit of
lag time compared to this is very quick
yeah definitely some lag time on the
ipad pro
just to switch to another photo and i do
want to test out some modifications so
let's quickly
adjust the exposure as you can see
basically instant on
this guy and on the ipad pro
yeah it's so responsive no issues right
there
now i just selected the healing brush
just to see if there's any lag on that
guy so
oh there you go there was definitely
some issues there but it happened pretty
quickly
let's do the same thing here whoa that
was fast too
and it did a better job i don't know why
but the ipad pro it almost seemed like
it was faster
and there's less issues like there are
here interesting
but now let's get into the real test
which is going to help us see
if it does thermal throttle we're going
to select all the photos
on each of these and then we're going to
export them and one thing i do want to
mention is that both of these have
some grading and different stuff like
the shadows exposure contrast
and a little bit of sharpening applied
as well so let's go ahead and export
them all right so here we are we have
the 50 photo selected ready to edit i've
turned on some sharpening
output sharpening screen standard on
both of these
let's go ahead and go back i've set the
image quality to 80
on both of them three two one and
export so far the ipad pro is killing it
the macbook pro is definitely behind i'm
not sure why that is but
these are imported photos so not really
sure alright the ipad just finished
one minute in five seconds incredibly
fast that's faster than we
used to test these macbooks now i don't
know why this is taking so long but
we're just going to give it a little bit
more time the macbook pro
just finished right there i have no idea
why it took
5 minutes and 30 seconds it makes no
sense because the ipad only took a
minute so
i guess the clear thing that we can
answer is i don't know why it took that
long all the settings were the same
but the ipad pro definitely does not
throttle in this test
it's exporting those faster than
basically i've seen before which is
really really impressive and now let's
get into the big test this is
adobe premiere rush and as you can see
we're importing files
straight from the ipad pro and from the
mac we have five
video clips the same ones so let's go
ahead and we're gonna create
a video we're gonna do a little bit of
editing
we're gonna make the same edits on both
of these and then we're going to export
them all right let's do a little fade
add dissolve on both of these add in
some presets
let's add the same thing here let's add
this airy
preset to all of them and we're really
just doing this to give it a little bit
more work to do and more
processing and rendering and stuff like
that let's add in some kind of a graphic
all right we just made a few adjustments
and here we are ready to export
we made the same changes the resolution
everything is set to the same
high quality and let's go ahead and
export
three two one go and i do want to throw
on
this thermal camera and just measure the
thermals to see
i don't know if if the ipad gets more
hot all right guys as you can see we
have some hot spots definitely near the
bottom of the ipad pro
and right there in the center that's
probably where that m1 chip is
but we've got 33 degrees celsius hottest
point on the ipad
31 hottest point on the macbook
pro back to the ipad 32
right there at the bottom interesting
what about this little spot right there
33 i just saw in the middle and look at
that
30 back on the macbook pro so the
macbook pro is definitely staying cooler
but we're not seeing crazy temps on that
ipad so that
is reassuring like the cooling is
actually really really good
on this ipad i'm so impressed with that
m1 chip and how thin it is
all right i can't believe this guy so
far the ipad pro is winning
same everything same setting same every
this is
this is crazy the ipad pro just finished
and the macbook pro is still going oh my
goodness done
the macbook pro just finished that is
insane we have two minutes and 43
seconds for the m1 ipad pro
and three minutes and 27 seconds for the
m1
macbook pro that's a difference of
around 45 seconds
i don't know what apple is doing but
they are insane
i thought that the m1 chip was overkill
for the ipad pro but apparently not
because it is absolutely killing it and
in multiple tests
we are not seeing thermal throttling it
just doesn't make sense because
i expected the 12.9 inch model to be
fine
but the 11 inch model that is not any
thicker than last year's
and of course the chassis is smaller so
it has less room to work with
in terms of cooling and it's just not
throttling
this is nuts all right and now there is
one more test that i want to run to see
if it's going to get hot and
throttle but before that i just want to
mention that through every single test
that we just ran
the only one that showed any signs of
throttling
was geekbench 5 in the multi-core test
where the macbook pro was 20
faster but it seems like in real world
tasks
it just doesn't care lightroom and
rush were incredibly fast and
specifically rushed was faster than the
macbook pro which is just
insane apple has completely just knocked
it out of the park with this ipad pro so
let's put this aside and the last test
we're doing
is we're going to run gynshin impact the
game that's
so intense that it always dims the
display
on the iphone 12 pro so
let's see if we can get this to run very
hot
this time we're gonna set the brightness
to the max
boom highest overclocked we're setting
everything to as high as possible
fps turning up to 60 sucks you can't do
more than that
visual effects highest highest highest
highest highest
yeah so far so good this performance
killer no issues
that is bright this is not the mini led
display but it is bright for sure i'm
feeling this and it's
not that hot so i've been playing ginger
impact for about
10-15 minutes at maxed out brightness so
far
absolutely zero display dimming not at
all and the back doesn't even feel hot i
don't know what apple's doing but
they're crazy
i just want to check the temps right now
let's see 39 at the bottom i don't know
why it's so hot down there but right in
the center is about 38
so it's definitely a little bit hot but
it's nowhere
near where it could be like it's staying
really cool
not hot enough to basically make the
display dim or anything
i think it's safe to say based off all
of the testing that i did
the m1 ipad pro even the 11 inch does
not
thermal throttle compared to the macbook
pro
it's just killer like i don't know what
kind of cooling system apple put in
there but it is absolutely amazing so
there you guys go i hope that answers
your question and if you enjoyed the
video
go ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe because we're going to be
doing a bunch of videos on those
other 12.9 inch ipad pros comparisons
and everything
compared to the 2020 ipad pro and we
also got the 24 inch
imac and we're about to start doing a
video on that as well so
if you enjoyed it definitely subscribe
check out one of those two videos right
there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video